demande physique de ce fonds pour la
suite de youtube arzel parce qu'on aille
du tube aux affaires devenir numéro un
mondial
alors elle été collectées n'ont pas
suffit d'être majuscule n'ont pas suffi
non plus alors c'est tout à notre truc
n'oubliez pas objectif le million
d'euros pas d'abonnés l'attention sa
black lui on va chercher un appartement
est en coloc mon gars il faut 60 dollars
et on peut partir vivre en colocation
avec un poteau à nous amodio sexuelle ce
qui se passe tout à rien ce bouton on
off avec notre d'oncle apparemment on
peut améliorer nos styles grâce à cette
nouvelle bibliothèque
ikea va pas se mentir regardez puis ça
c'est bon ça ça coûte de la thune
d'accord doivent être tous ou sur huit
pour cent oui j'aurais jamais je
n'aurais jamais dû emménager alors là
c'est un petit vidéos gaming appliquée
et je vous paye
voilà on n'est pas du tout désespéré a
nommé la vidéo en ligne ah ça c'est mon
coloc c'est ça alors lui faire un câlin
aux fins cas là il nous a repoussé mais
je vais tuer allez on continue on fait
des vidéos là pour le kiff pour l'argent
et on va pas se mentir on a peint tout
cas payé les gars je suis désolé à un
moment où on va on va chercher abonnés
alors nouvelle vidéo gameplay ont fait
que ça chaque nouvelle vidéo sur le même
jeu à chaque fois ci mène la même vidéo
sipri un nordmann à tous et andy le
clash
ça fera début on va travailler pendant
que sa peau de mecs c'est super de 8
heures 40 $ malus à ces notions que
j'avais pas vu dans l'épisode avant que
sako était toute en neige d'études c'est
qu'on peut aller travailler
voilà on va picard on vend nos petits
surgelés on revient on peut s'acheter un
jeu et faire de meilleures vidéos super
elle est rendue en cour au manger un
sandwich et on va travailler on va
charles monnet
fateh des envies plein les yeux des
poils flights elle c'est nul on en vient
de perdre tous nos abonnés suite à cette
blague
alors qu'est ce qu'on veut faire
entendre la vidéo buzz pas trop trop ça
c'est ma mamma colloque
elle m'a invité à voir film bon allez
allez allez on a droit un petit plaisir
en tant que tu veux regarder à rigoler
c'est mort tu fais début du fait de la
thune non merci
dégage du charbon gauche opinion à
acheter le nouveau jeu tendance qui
bosse ça se fait sortir ça donne machin
on commence un froid cette vidéo sur
rivière saloon kingdoms est un poteau
qui veut qu'on fasse ça c'est sûr zbox
[ __ ] ça va être cher faut réparer pc
parce que l'hôtel avait bien utiliser
l'app était sale [ __ ] jetez pas sur un
site porno il ya des spams horrible
bosses du coup on va dormir chez moi qui
l'aurai pas aller on lui fait confiance
aux ivoiriens boulaye arnavaux les mecs
qui en a dormi séparer cela on sait
qu'on a dormi vraiment une seconde si on
regarde bien la siesta plus corps du
monde
il ya une rumeur disant que tu fais que
des vidéos pour l'argent non non non non
les millions je pense qu'il serait mieux
d'ignorer ces rumeurs de merde c'est ben
haddou tu penses que je refuse que des
gens osent ça a beau regarder j'étais
sincère mais abonnés ont kiffé je suis
content de super on va dormir manger
charbonné acheter la zbox a les moyens
on a pris un mac de ce qui n'empêche pas
des vidéos on fait une super vidéo là
est ce que tu veux chatter banon mais à
chaque îlot mais qu'il demande de chat
et au moment où j'en suis rendu ta vidéo
des super chiant et riche peut pas
chatter avec l'olp et s'est occupé
hockey et faire d'argent plus important
avec tes cheveux vers bata j'espère
vraiment qu'il ya des joueurs qui vont
prendre exemple sur ce jeu pour faire
des vidéos [ __ ] alors nouveau je fais
le 28 février
samurai spelling c'est super ça ça comme
bollaert a demandé à l'éditeur de
l'envoyer à léon pèse notre appart et où
vingt mille abonnés s'te plaît j'attends
le collier ont fait directement vidéo tu
dirais qu'il est là c'est parti
fertil fraîcheur qui vient sortir alors
la mecque ça va ça va cartonner on
annonce la couleur buzz mondial ont vu
eric qui veut chat et même et ça sketch
eric aux cheveux verts je sais pas
changé d'horaire mec tu veux un regain
avec moi et mes gros ça ou pas alors
contactez moi une autre heure alors il y
en a qui nous propose 240 $ pour on
accepte qu'on sait pas ce qu'elle veut
mais on accepte on a reçu le jeu on dort
on fait la vidéo sur le jeu pour les 240
dollars juste un mec oh là là éclater
une coda
on va faire la vidéo ce que jeux vidéos
sponsorisées je suis honnête donc laïque
et la vidéo d'un buzz mondial en vue
50000 vu mes mecs mais mec mec notre vie
on a un temps dans le village alberto
les 51 bonne et on va bientôt pouvoir
acheter une villa à voir chef cuistot on
va dormir la vidéo sponso et en ligne du
combat touché beaucoup d'argent mais est
ce qu'il vaut pas mieux acheter du matos
pour améliorer l'inquiéter nos vidéos pc
world
mais comme astronaute pc gamer assez
cher à sa pique bon dans le doute on se
prend celui-là [ __ ] mais qu'au secours
d'un pc là on a de nouveau fait c'est
incroyable
non non des problèmes de droits offerts
sur nos vidéos c'est la chaîne et strike
et elle va fermer aux trois piliers
d'argent on pourra plus faire des vidéos
parce qu'on aime ça ok ok on va résoudre
ce problème la spree la vidéo c'est ça
on la supprime on la supprime voilà il
faut qu'on leur fasse huit mois abonnez
vous nous faire la gueule plus tard
c'est parra va revenir en force avec une
vidéo exclusive sur une console qu'on
n'avait pas on va prendre là on est
plein studio claque est un nouveau jeu
qui vient de sortir je n'ai pas prise
pour rien qu'ils s'appellent au nez
plein studio chiffres correspondent
assez oui oh là là là là le buzz bon ok
la console et la malaisie est le jeu le
jeu le jeu ok super première impression
parce qu'il vient de sortir à temps est
sorti merde jusqu'au 1er juin près que
sur tient longtemps le conte eric qu'il
veut chat et au moment de plus la vidéo
eric je suis désolé je suis désolé
alors oui on est dans lequel j'étais un
petit dodo sponso d'offrir du bien là
nous faut une vidéo de camicas bowling
sur la nique aux sons of the box où je
m'en bats les couilles bossent comme des
fils de chien ans l'achète invitation à
un événement
aucun autre atelier pour aller à cette
fameuse présentation met sur pied des
[Musique]
arbres la petite réunion de l'après
chaud on va pouvoir parler à des youtube
heures je veux être seul actuellement ne
me fais pas chier ou la grosse tête la
grosse tête ça y est allé je me barre
d'ici ça craint c'est pas tout mais on a
des vidéos à faire nous ok alors
nouvelles webcams nouveau microphone
watsoft cousettes on a une tête ce soir
bon ok ok ok allez allez on a bien
mérité mais qui alors autour travail il
faut s'abonner à lesparre six nouvelles
vidéos mon gamin tout défoncer objectif
l'umih l'oms vue je partagerai l'argent
avec vous chers abonnés parce que je
vous aime vous l'a finalement autant
écrire un livre togo faire un titre
aussi l'on peut le faire enfin guy
mollet parce que j'adore mais les
abonnés je vais gagner cette figurine en
plastique de leur décision c'est pas mon
but c'était bien une plastique j'aurais
pu faire gagner une plante les années
cinquante mille abonnés c'est quoi c'est
un nouveau style vestimentaire
ok on est sur asos.fr on va prendre le
dessus très bien beau de vitesse pour
fumel ce super ça les gens vont adorer
bordel et après un petit short là un
tout petit champ une jeune tu paies tu
peux être ministre fort female on
l'apprend chaussures qu'est ce qu'on en
a pas les petites chaussures à talons
mines et des tombes mais c'est bien ça à
plat aux jeunes allez petit monde les
miens moi un petit foulard rouge si
mignon alors là comment se relever mon
gars ya parfois qu'on achète des
vêtements en six ans attention petite
vidéo en attendant on va pas se mentir
en attendant ma commande à gauche
voilà bah ouais non nés dans une récente
sincérité avec nos abonnés faut pas
l'oublier
hop hop au mondue avec les tongs plus
tard c'est beau la là qu'on est beau
ce jour est enfin arrivé c'est une
nouvelle vie qui s'offre à nous
tellement nouvelle vie qu'on va changer
d'appartement on va partir sur un 2
pièces embaucher des synodes
colocataires vient pas avec nous ont
fait route seul bros désolé
oh mon dieu a trahi super bien sa part
qui perd lumineux vraiment à f2 de
qualité en plus sur la loue et
meublaient mon avis maintenant que d
instaurer la paf notre objectif c'est de
trouver un collaborateur tu pourras
faire des vidéos pour notre chaîne
youtube
davoc de faudrait qu'on aille à un
événement il ya plein de youtube heures
précédant choper un comme ça l'attaché
des bulls et non à des poteaux l on peut
l'inviter bien la maison on va parler à
acheter on va l'inviter work on track
on l'emploie ça y est elle est là on va
lui demander de faire des vidéos super
glauque [ __ ] d'entre les esclaves ou
veulent la tuer elle va faire la vie
dure à ma place mais mec c'est glauque
de ouf la passion et la cua [ __ ] elle
a intérêt à bosser parce que mais
qu'apparemment on la paye mais cacher
quoi aux caisses mais à travailler bien
c'est pour ça alors elle a fait la vidéo
maintenant on décide sur le plot doux
pas alors howell a fait un truc super
c'est très bien on applaudit game over
donc ayem over pour ayoub expliquez moi
j'ai fait une vidéo tellement merdique
que je suis luminus à youtube de ban
c'est quoi ce bordel mon gars
[Musique]